listen I got a lot of questions about
series I had so much fun with it but I
do have to ask Darren an individual
question just start things off um what
was cooler you got the voice at the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle and a
transformer and I need to know which one
with that boy don't you don't want to
start that fight man but that's that's
an internal conflict that I think will
be a life long saga jeez yeah I have to
pinch myself I I mean let's not shoot
let's not pick our favorite children but
you know let's just say that Raphael
might have a little more immediate name
value than sideswipe so you know I get
getting to be a Transformers dope but
you know a lot of great people have a
voiced Raphael and so getting to dip my
foot in that pond is is is a feather in
my cap I don't think I would have ever
guessed I would be able to procure so
thank you for leading with that though
because I guarantee you none of my
co-stars know that that's something that
I've ever done I didn't know that
talking into why I get to talk to you
guys today first Congrats on the series
that watch the whole thing I had blast
with it so well done the thing that I
really wanted to talk about right from
the get-go is Ryan Murphy
I love his commitment to diversity and
inclusion both in front of and behind
the camera I wanted to know if all three
of you could talk about that and how
important that is representation I
really like that Ryan Murphy calls it
faction so you have fictional characters
and characters who would he lived at
those times and he has a great way of
walking that fine line between having
the most fun and it's so luxurious and
glamorous and heartbreaking at the same
time and really putting a microscope on
really real flaws that are in our
business and that are still relevant
today
Ryan is someone that I
admired and looked up to for a very long
time from clean with their and then to
the pose in American Horror Story he's
just been so at the forefront of
representation in front of us behind the
camera she said so it was really cool to
obviously be a part of this but it was
even cooler to be able to be telling
stories of people who have been
marginalized throughout Hollywood
throughout the years and who have been
underrepresented and to look at what
could the world looks like how they've
been representation in the forties and
at the beginning of Hollywood and if
those changes that were starting to see
today in Hollywood had been able to be
made then I think the world would be it
kind of a much brighter more inclusive
place so it was you know the sort of
this lovely revisionist history of
Hollywood that was really training to be
able to think about I will say that you
know representation and inclusion has
been Ryan Murphy's MO since since day
one his entire career has been this
incredible crusade for advocacy for all
types of historically marginalized
people and that theme has been really
predominant and almost everything he's
ever touched so Hollywood is certainly
no exception but he does it in a really
fun way I mean what's so great is he he
creates these really fun worlds whether
it's you know your bag or not whatever
show he's made is is an undeniably a
specific world that when you're done
watching it you kind want to go back
you're like I like existing in that plan
and a little bit whether it's a version
of how we wish the world to be or a very
harsh scary version of a perverted
version of what it actually is so he
kind of you know he chose that line
between you know showing us enough of
what really is to make us consider the
possibility of what it should be and
yeah it's it's always fun to be part of
a Ryan project for that reason because
you also know it's going to look and
feel great but there's a sort of an
added bonus value of being part of a
much more important social discussion
one of the things I really liked about
our and Laura's relationship in the show
is that in any other show you guys would
be arch enemies fighting all the time
and I love that it's not that that
you're both actually wishing each other
on and you know it's nothing not what
you normally see I'm sure to talk about
that relationship I mean that's
something that we said initially just to
each other first reading of the scribes
I mean we loved that it was sort of this
shift of I think you know the the two
girls fighting each other and arguing
and became sort of this great female
friendship within this place where they
normally would have been pitted against
each other and instead of that they come
together for the greater good of
students kind of you know making a world
a better place like through Hollywood
and they really team up for that so it
was really exciting
yeah and they find similarities in their
lives that that are very unexpected and
I love that about them that they could
connect on a level that you wouldn't
normally see in the 1940s between a
white woman and a black woman one of the
things I don't know if any of you guys
read comic books growing up but there
was a comic book called what if and it's
like what if Batman had beaten Superman
in that epic fighter
it's like these alt universes one one in
stores and that's what I think this
series is what if Hollywood had embraced
diversity and sexuality in the 1940
I mean fact even you you have nailed
something that I've mentioned in in
previous interviews which is the 1940s
especially 1940s Hollywood to me is such
a potent genre in and of itself much
like the mythology of Greek mythology or
comic books you know there are there's
like cannon right there are the
characters and tales of certain people
that certain people know would you hear
the one about Katherine you hear the one
about this you know they everybody has
these stories that have been told you
know some probably more apocryphal than
others but we we look to these people on
this time like we look at superheroes of
this other thing that so much
bigger than theirs like social media and
you couldn't connect with them on such a
personal level it made them even more
mysterious and more mythical and more
grand and time has only sort of
fermented that you know more with more
and more glitz and glamour and mystery
so back to the comic book thing you know
we are doing that sort of alternate
universe thing which seems to be very
unbowed right now with a lot of shows
you know what what if this one thing had
happened and you know that's what's so
fun about again this this almost genre
it feels like a genre even though it is
actually a period piece is that you know
there are certain types of people's and
like tropes and and cara archetypes that
we are familiar with through being fans
of Hollywood and and the history of
Hollywood and we kind of give it this
sort of as Ryan Murphy said factional
look of yeah what would it be different
if you know they had broken Batman's
back and all he's saying you know
there's different universes that what
happens if we had smashed through a lot
of the prejudiced barriers a lot sooner
what would that have looked like and
yeah that's what's so cool about this
there's enough of that sort of fantasy
element but it's rooted in the rulebook
of what would have been you know the the
the obstacles at the time so it's a it's
it's a it toes along really nicely I
think between fantasy in fact and in
fact III a hundred percent agree I'm
just about out of time I have to ask an
individual question use Samara I am I
don't think I could put into words how
excited I am for the Bill and Ted sequel
here
here's today yes could not be more
excited I need to know what the hell was
it like being a part of that movie and
what can you tease people about yeah
well my character I play Alex and his
daughter but named after Kiana's
character so I'm fear its Theodore
Preston let's just say the apple doesn't
fall far from the
in terms of the daughters of Bill and
Ted and the stakes are a lot higher this
time than just trying to get an a on a
history check how could it be any higher
than that how dare you but it was
honestly home it was more exciting for
my fiancee to be honest because growing
up in Australia and growing up overseas
I didn't know the Bill and Ted universe
until I got the audition and then
watched the movies and completely fell
in love with that over-the-top amazing
sort of Wayne's World comedy style so I
was just thrilled and terrified to be
thrown in the deep end of doing a true
comedy on that note I can't wait to see
it Congrats on the show to all three of
you have a fantastic day